senior political analyst britt hume is
here with us tonight good evening Brett
hi Brett so uh first let's start with
the McCabe situation the fallout from
the firing and and what has transpired
over the past couple of days Brett I see
very little basis based on what we know
now to think that this firing was
anything but on the up-and-up
this inquiry that it grew out of the
Inspector General's investigation has
been going on I guess back back back
before Trump was president and it came
across things about McCabe leaks that he
was involved in and then the lack of
candor is it was put to investigators
about it that's a very big deal inside
the FBI the matter was then that piece
of it was past the end of the the FBI's
own Office of Professional
Responsibility which looked at it and
recommended that that McCabe be fired
there's been a lot of criticism that the
firing was rushed but McCabe was on the
verge of retirement after which he could
not be fired
so the firing came at the very very last
minute it seems to me that far from
being rushed it may have been it may
have been held off until you know they
were facing a deadline after which he
couldn't be fired yeah so it looks to me
it's on the up and up who won't know
everything until the inspector general's
report comes out and we know the you
know more about the facts upon which it
was based but it looks looks looks okay
to me
yeah talking to senators Grassley and
Graham last week the list of questions
they had and calling for a special
counsel seems like they know much more
about what's in that IG report that's
upcoming to Muller now the the talk
around town is you know the question is
the president going to fire Muller or
somehow set the stage for that your
thoughts well he certainly did step up
his criticism of Muller and as was noted
earlier he mentioned him by name
and that's provoked all the speculation
and he's about to drop the hammer on him
I have my doubts though Bret I noticed
that the Ty Cobb who speaks for the
president said oh you know just the last
24 hours that he had no plans or isn't
even discussing doing and of course the
president must be aware that the last
time that was true
was by Richard Nixon dealing what was
with a special prosecutor and the
consequence of that was he got another
special prosecutor and the investigation
went on and led ultimately to where he
was upon the verge of being impeached so
I suspect he's aware that getting rid of
this special prosecutor would only oh
this special counsel would only would
only generate another one and he'd be
right back where he started from this is
not unprecedented and his the unpressed
didn't turn out very well for the person
who did the firing right but as far as
the public talk of a special counsel you
covered a white house which which did
that as well
well we certainly are this this stuff
we're hearing said which on did you know
as Kevin pointed out in his report this
is you know appears to be right out of
the Clinton playbook where you you know
you don't fire the the special
prosecutor or special counsel what you
do is you try to either soften him up by
criticizing him or you try to discredit
him so that if he comes out something
that's adverse to you it won't be
believed my own guess is that that
probably won't work if that's what he's
trying to do and I don't think that the
president's comments over the weekend
about the McCabe firing were helpful at
all in the sense that his gloating over
it only added to the suspicion that he
was somehow behind it although it's very
difficult to figure out how that would
have worked Brett as always thank you